oh it's you
it's been a long time
[Music]
kill off sons of [ __ ] right
[Music]
has been decided valve has no more
chances and must pay 3 million
Australian dollars hot gaben you suck so
much penis that make it video games the
only thing that's keeping counter-strike
alive is all as all the eSports behind
it for a company that makes so much
money valve is surprisingly risk-averse
they also seem in the main to be people
that are people that just don't want the
spotlight people just don't really want
to be out there but there is something
really admirable about the fact that
valve makes games because they think
that that game can change everything
rise and shine mr. Freeman now for all
of the smoke and mirrors valve isn't a
faceless corporate entity quite the
opposite its face is very well known and
loved
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the International
without CEO and founding partner Gabe
Newell or gaben as he is commonly
referred to has cemented his spot as a
benevolent god of gamers worldwide
hi my name is Gabe Newell I'm the
managing director at mouth our first
game was half-life and I'd like to say
hello to all the game star readers
valves journey began in 1996 when gaben
left Microsoft with fellow employee Mike
Harrington to found their own gaming
development company we both thought that
there was a pretty good chance that we
were gonna go take a stab at this for a
year failed miserably and then suck our
tails between our legs and go back to
working at Microsoft the pair was
convinced that video games were the
future of entertainment and were eager
to throw their hats into the ring we're
gonna be seeing these guys a lot tonight
half-life Harrington eventually split
from valve leaving the company entirely
in gaben's capable hands sitting at over
a four billion dollar net worth valves
president somehow manages to project and
maintain a down-to-earth everyman image
even going so far as publicly sharing
his email should anyone want to get in
touch please email me at gaben at valve
software comm and let me know about your
rampage I'm not wearing underwear as
unlikely as direct communication with a
billionaire seems the email address is
in fact real and functional and a lucky
few get a response now in them however
following that story hitting some
mainstream media attention Gabe Newell
started to answer quite a few community
questions regarding the situation of
these layoffs and if they had affected
valves developments in any way first of
all mr. Newell answered the question
that it was 13 full-time employees and
it was a people thing not a hardware
thing valve is often hailed for their
contribution to the growth of the gaming
industry particularly the creation and
development of steam a digital gaming
distribution platform so influential it
has become synonymous with PC gaming in
general they've contributed an enormous
amount to helping these ecosystem
overall and they've stayed hands off
here's some tools here's some stuff
we'll try and support you where we can
but otherwise please get on with it just
like valve itself steam has changed
dramatically over the years it was first
introduced on September 12 2003 as a way
for gamers to keep their valve titles
patch
and up-to-date at a time when only about
20% of people had a broadband connection
in their home requiring users to be
connected constantly it was a tall order
and so steam floundered before scene was
even a twinkle in Gavin's eye valve put
out a few titles most notably the
universally acclaimed FPS phenomenon
half-life good morning and welcome to
the Black Mesa Transit System
this automated train is provided for the
security and convenience of the Black
Mesa research facility personnel
halflife assured in a new generation of
FPS games receiving numerous best game
awards and even leading to
counter-strike which was originally a
mod of that game it was just one of many
mods that got dropped out of half not
out of half-life being the most amazing
game engine the fanbase clamored for a
sequel and valve delivered rise and
shine mr. Freeman
[Music]
half left to was incredible such a
revolutionary game from a lot of
perspectives and the thing that really
stands out about it is that just like
half like one totally changed for a 15
shooters half-life 2 just did it again
it did that same kind of rollercoaster e
style of like you know you're just being
pushed through levels but it had things
that were totally different levels that
really stood out
obviously the gravity gun is like the
huge standout that everybody remembers
but there are plenty of things in
half-life 2 that made people just lose
their minds feel like they were playing
video games again for the first time but
there was a catch the only way to get
your hands on half-life 2 was to sign up
for Steam making half-life 2 the vehicle
that made steam more than a failed
experiment but there was a catch you
seemed half-life 2 required you to log
in the steam and download it through
Steam you couldn't just go ahead and
play the game freely and I'm telling you
a lot of people did not know this and
when I say a lot I mean a lot instantly
valve had ingeniously locked people into
getting Steam and with an influx of
users the platform grew in 2005 valve
allows third-party releases onto steam
for a cut of the profits made from
digital sales ragdoll Kongfu and
darwinian or the first non valve games
made available on Steam marking its
transition into a fully functional
digital store as more and more titles
came pouring in it was full steam ahead
for valve
[Applause]
by 2010 valve made more profit per
employee than either Google or Apple in
short valve as [ __ ] you
actually in the [ __ ] we month today ste
monopolizes a significant portion of the
digital sales market for games by moving
their wares from the physical to the
digital realm valve kick-started a
change that helped revolutionize the way
we consume media steam created the
digital market and it nurtured it grew
it into a multi-billion dollar industry
to the point where most PC players don't
buy any physical games and those that do
aren't surprised to find a steam key
inside their game cakes but Java wasn't
just concerned with the digital
migration of games the company's foray
into the world of user-generated content
has also been a huge success
valve bought the intellectual property
rights to counter-strike a mod of
Valve's own half-life in 1999 in 2010
valve acquired the rights to dota 2 a
mod of a warcraft 3 map from its lead
developer icefrog and creator mule
needles to say both dota 2 and CS have
been extremely worthwhile investments
every time that you guys play a match or
create an item or contribute to the
compendium you're helping make dota
better for the rest of us valve also
created a space for users to submit
their own content including mods and
cosmetics that others could purchase
through Steam and not only that they
will ship in very supportive original is
a mod dota is of mod underdogs is kind
of an evolution of a mod of the game and
so they've been very open to that
they've hired people in allowing
user-generated content to flourish on
Steam turned out to be a bit of a
double-edged sword though valve embraced
it for it's obvious Vantage's a fast
turnover of ideas and free beta testing
of new concepts all done by the
itself at no cost to the gaming joint
here at valve we have a unique
perspective on EGC some of our most
popular game franchises started off as
mods of other dance because of this
background many of our products directly
support UGC in one way or another so
we've truly seen the power of it
firsthand the disadvantages of course
were the torrents of content being added
to steam some of it poorly made or
offensive but the floodgate had been
opened
internally valve went through some
significant changes since its early days
the company chose to phase out the
levels of its corporate hierarchy Valve
decide of it labeling anything other
than the top execs manager was redundant
and stifling the employees could now
move freely between projects and
departments putting their creative
talents towards what ever happened to
strike their fancy in theory the lack of
structure would allow for a greater
freedom of expression and a flow of
creative juices within the company it
all makes you wonder how does Valve
maintain focus with such an open
structure how does a company this
unpredictable decide what it wants to do
next and above all what sort of people
does it take to succeed in this type of
environment the downside of course was
more accountability for individual
mistakes for a company that makes so
much money valve is surprisingly
risk-averse new projects internal tools
delve in for Devon for structure and
anything that doesn't contribute to a
current product are met with the stain
this is only meaningful to company
rockstars but there are necessary tasks
that comes with producing successful
products that people are reluctant to
pick up at times because they're not
sick because they're not sexy products
not having a managerial system in place
also meant deadlines weren't being
enforced and projects were sometimes
left to languish for years or just
cancelled outright and the departure of
talent who led the work on earlier
releases left several big titles in
limbo but left 4 dead 3 was cancelled
late 2016 or early 2017 because the team
couldn't make a decision on exactly what
engine they were
continue developing and so an almost
finished game only meaning the final
passes art and voice acting was
cancelled and never to be seen again
the community began to question whether
the developers at valve were capable of
counting to three as any significant
releases seemed stuck on their second
iterations left 4 dead 2 Team Fortress 2
half-life 2 episode 2 the list goes on
your motivation is 3 kills just give me
anything anything you want say whatever
ok I don't I don't care you've killed
more than 2 people in less than 4 now
until very recently half-life 3 was the
primary entry on that list of unrealized
thirds but after a 15 year wait the fans
can finally look forward to a new
installment of the beloved franchise
half-life Alex in VR while it is a
prequel not a sequel and the VR bit of
the announcement was a disappointment
for some fans there's no doubt that the
long anticipated release got a lot of
hearts pumping you got to realize people
been waiting 20 years or more for four
you know this stuff
okay a question that often comes up
where valve is concerned is whether
valve is truly the good guy the
community makes it out to be
despite the billion dollar offer CEO
Gabe Newell said valve would rather
disintegrate than ever sell out too
often valve has been an absent parent to
some of its releases allowing bugs to
wreak havoc on in-game economies and
opie guns to destroy metas okay is that
how counter-strike works now this guy's
just gonna go like that and I'm dead you
literally see like his [ __ ] shoulder
patch and you just die from a pistol
from that far away god gaben you suck so
much penis and making video games it
[ __ ] hurts me bro it [ __ ] you're
so rich it's insane how could you not
fix this [ __ ] game sorry sorry Chet
and fed up gamers are not the only ones
finding fault with how valve conducts
itself in the landmark or case of valve
versus the Australian government the
company was found to be in violation of
the country's good business practices
and was ordered to pay a three million
dollar fine as a result then as of June
2015 valve started offer refunds across
their entire storefront and found that
only argued this was sufficient but they
did not need to follow local law because
their company does not operate locally
the ACCC said no to both of these things
and after appeals it has been decided
valve has no more chances and must pay
three million Australian dollars before
the historic ruling took place valve
never offered refunds of any kind on any
of their digital purchases if you bought
something from Steam the sale was final
in what was seen as a gesture of
goodwill by valve towards their consumer
base all refund requests made within 14
days of purchase or before the game was
played for more than two hours were
automatically approved it wasn't any
grand gesture on Valve's part as so many
had treated them as the last great broke
consumer entity out there at the time it
was due to legal pressures as a result
of this one lawsuit and as I said valves
implementing their refund policy was not
out of any pro-consumer leading it was
fully motivated out of self-preservation
and self-interest the Australian case
wasn't the first or the last time valve
found itself embroiled in a lengthy
court battle former partner disputes
intellectual prop
ownership claims consumer rights group
lawsuits scheme gambling scandals geo
blocking accusations valves legal
history is a dark and thorny place and
the law isn't the only thing that valve
has had to struggle against it's not
half-life 3 for what it's worth it's not
a new hero but valve has a new game
coming soon you're not giving me the
appropriate reaction that deserves
artifact Valve's first release in years
bombed so badly that 95% of its active
player base dropped the game a mere two
months in or a destroy an enemy artifact
but artifact is already dead by july
2019 the game boasted fewer than a
hundred players putting artifact into
its own category of dead game artifact
simply had too many problems deep rooted
issues with the gameplay and the fact
that the game wasn't free-to-play unlike
some of its biggest competitors left
loyal valve fans tangibly disappointed I
will be really disappointed if the
economy ends up being just like the
biggest shortcoming with the game
because I really actually enjoy the game
itself but I mean they can't release it
like this combined these factors led to
artifacts swift demise but I do wish we
could have figured out a way to manage
our relationship with the with the fans
better because because in the end I
think that the game was a very very good
game but not necessarily for everybody
but just because artifact got off to a
rough start it doesn't mean that Valve
has given up on it just yet
any definite revival plans however are
yet to be announced
not one to be deterred by a silly thing
like a failed game valve continued
working on its many other ventures the
International 2019 had over 1.1 million
viewers on Twitch during the grand
finals the most ever for a dota 2 event
steams remote play together beta feature
was expanded to all users and valve
announced that planes were already in
the works for the next two csgo majors
additionally in light of the success of
mods like dota auto chess valve is
looking to reach deeper into the gaming
market in countries like China where
steam currently operates under great
market conditions according to reports
the steam store is still accessible but
the writing may very well be on the wall
for the valve run gaming website in
China and if that's the case the valve
will be feeling the pinch and to add to
the growing list of its new undertakings
in 2018 valve accidentally went live
with a test server of steam TV valves
own broadcasting platform and a possible
rival to twitch this does raise a few
questions is valve attempting to take on
the twitch the mixture the YouTube
gaming marketplace and if so will they
have any kind of revenue incentives for
the people streaming on their platform
valve has developed a reputation for
playing favorites with their games as I
mentioned before I looked into dota 2 a
little but when I went through the pages
of the update history for dota 2 it
seems that they update their game pretty
much daily with fixes and every month
comes the fixes to champions or some
massive content update every valve
release since 2004 has been running
under once groundbreaking engine source
and so far the only game valve ported
over to source 2 has been dota 2
meanwhile Valve's other smash hit csgo
continues to suffer from a plethora of
game breaking bugs frustrating his
competitive community the only thing
that's keeping Garrick alive is all as
all the eSports behind it all the others
all the organisers what's keeping it
alive but the game itself as a whole is
dying with none of these updates as
there are two biggest esports
investments however neither dota 2 or
csgo are likely to go anywhere any
soon at this point there's no telling
exactly how lofty valve's ambitions are
valve seems to only be interested in
making games when it's this huge
earth-changing event right when it's tf2
basically inventing the class-based
shooter when it's half-life and
half-life 2 revitalizing FPS is when
it's half-life Alex trying to be the
game that sells people on VR valve wants
to do the things that nobody else has
done and they're not doing it out of the
goodness of their heart they want to
make money but there is something really
admirable about the fact that Valve
makes games because they think that that
game can change everything the question
is has valve to live long enough to see
itself become the gaming industry's
villain or have they been unfairly
painted as one by making decisions they
feel or important rather than bending to
public opinion a couple years ago we
started to think we started to have
these weird thoughts about economies and
the importance of user-generated content
and how the process that had given rise
to steam was actually accelerating and
that the most important developers were
actually our customers a very normal I
would call normal gaming fad you know
they're fans of games they love games as
soon as we do but they are in a
fortunate position where they can
produce these things and they can adapt
to change games but they also seem in
the main to be people that are people
that just don't want the spotlight just
don't really want to be out there no
matter what the answer it's millions of
people will always hold on to the valve
that they remember the valve that didn't
just raise the bottom but defined it
whatever you think of them today valve
set the benchmark every other gaming
company strives to reach and no matter
what not legacy is
but I think we can put our differences
behind us for science you monster
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]